Salut la team Mentalo
Aujourd'hui on va parler d'astrologie
Je sais ce n'est pas du tout le sujet que je vous avais annoncé lundi
mais entre temps, dans les commentaires
il y a eu une grosse discussion
sur les commentaires de la vidéo de vendredi dernier
concernant l'astrologie, les scientifiques...
Je ne suis pas intervenu dans votre discussion vous l'avez remarqué
parce que je me suis dis que c'était sympa
de faire une vidéo, du coup, sur ce thème là.
Et là vous vous dites :
Alors il est pour qui Fabien?
Et bien je ne suis pour ni l'un ni l'autre
et les deux en même temps.
La bonne technique du mec qui se mouille pas.
L'astrologie c'est une croyance avant tout
comme toutes les croyances, ça veut dire
qu'elle peut être vérifiable et validée par une autre croyance qu'est le monde scientifique
ou alors pas du tout et qu'elle ne concernera toujours
uniquement les gens qui y croient.
Donc comme toutes les croyances, elle se respecte.
Par contre quand on est mentaliste
c'est très intéressant de prendre en compte
le rapport à l'astrologie.
Tout d'abord parce que de nombreux astrologues...
Alors attention, petit point quand même
je ne dis pas qu'il y a des vrais, des faux, des charlatans, des pas charlatans...
Je prends juste le point de vue mentaliste.
Donc je disais certains astrologues
usent et abusent de l'effet barnum
des lieux communs...
Et nous avec notre petit recadrage
on a l'impression qu'il s'adresse à nous
à notre personne.
Je vais vous lire un extrait d'Angel Stagnaro à ce sujet
c'est pour ça que j'ai fais la vidéo d'ailleurs
parce que quand je lisais vos commentaires
ça m'a fait immédiatement penser à ça !
"J'ai compris l'efficacité d'utiliser
l'horoscope asiatique
quand un de mes amis qui y croyait furieusement
me l'a présenté.
Comme il s'était trompé sur mon année de naissance
il avait lu la description des caractéristiques
du mauvais signe.
J'ai été intrigué de voir à quel point
cette lecture semblait exacte.
Je lui ai donc demandé de me prêter ce livre.
J'ai vérifié une fois encore les dates
et j'ai trouvé l'erreur.
J'ai regardé l'horoscope qui correspondait
effectivement à mon année de naissance
et j'ai trouvé une autre lecture
encore une fois exacte."
C'est vrai qu'en ça, les recadrages, c'est très fort.
On a toujours l'impression que ça s'adresse à nous
et en tout cas, inconsciemment, on le raccroche à des choses qui vont fonctionner
et on va oublier ce qui ne fonctionne pas.
Au final, on va toujours se reconnaître.
Mais ce qui est très très intéressant, par contre, d'un point de vue société
c'est que toute sa vie, on va lire des descriptifs sur notre signe astrologique.
On va aller à la chasse à ça dans les bouquins
qu'on y croit ou pas, on est toujours tenté de lire la description de son signe
et les descriptions sont toujours les mêmes, évidemment.
Des traits de caractère principaux, ce que la personne aime ou n'aime pas,  ce pourquoi elle est faite...
On le lit tellement, on s'en imprègne tellement au cours de sa vie
qu'on peut s'y reconnaître les yeux fermés, même si c'est pas vraiment nous.
Je m'explique : par exemple, si je rencontre une personne qui est née le 27 mars, donc qui est bélier
je vais dire à cette personne qu'elle a plutôt besoin de liberté
que c'est quelqu'un de téméraire, que c'est une leader, que c'est quelqu'un  même d'un petit peu impulsive,
qui est franche et directe, qui aime l'aventure, mais qui est plutôt impatiente
voire même agressive, brutale, parfois.
Et je pense donc que cette personne là est bélier.
Bon, mais je savais qu'elle était bélier puisque, là, dans l'exemple,  je sais qu'elle est née le 27 mars.
La personne "bélier" va se reconnaître dans ces traits de caractère même si elle ne l'est pas
parce que tout au long de sa vie, c'est les traits de caractère du bélier qu'elle aura lu.
Donc elle s'est associée elle-même à ce qu'elle a lu tout le temps.
Et ça, c'est très intéressant, ça ne veut pas dire qu'elle est comme ça, ça veut dire qu'elle se reconnaît là-dedans.
Je vous ai fait le bélier, je vous cite rapidement tous les autres signes avec un moyen mnémotechnique
pour se rappeler des informations clés.
Pour taureau, je vous fait voir à chaque fois la lettre, à quoi elle me fait penser.
Tempéré, Aime la simplicité, immUable, Réaliste, EST obstiné et  AffectueUx.
Je vais faire comme ça pour chaque signe.
Gémaux: Généreux, EST insaisissable, iMaginatif, EST intElligent, négAtif, talentUeuX.
Talentueux dans le sens "multiples talents".
Cancer. Conservateur, Apathique, origiNal, Chaleureux, Energique, Romantique.
Lion. Leader,  optimIste, Original, Naturel et extraverti. On peut dire "lionne".
Vierge. Vraiment douée, Indécise, Esprit pratique, Raffinée, Grande intelligence et obsErvatrice.
Balance. Bon goût, impartiAl, frivoLe, Artiste,
"N", c'est le "N" de seNsible, réCeptif, Equilibré.
Scorpion. Sexualité très Contrôlée, Optimiste, Réservé en paroles,  Passionné, Intense,  Ouvert d'esprit, seNsible.
C'est encore le "N" de "sensible".
Sagittaire. Se suffit à lui-même, Actif, Généreux, Impatient, Très fiable et honnête, Très rigide, Adaptable, Idéaliste,
Réticent à manifester l'affection, et sincEre.
Et les trois derniers, donc, Capricorne :
Confiance en lui-même,  Autoritaire, Prévisible,  Résolu, Indépendant, Circonspect, Obstiné,
sûR,
c'est le "R" de la fin de "sûr".
Non frivole, et solidE.
Verseau. Vif, Est actif, Raisonnable, Sans préjugés, Est idéaliste, Aimable, et peU conventionnel.
C'est le "U" de "peu".
Alors, mon moyen mnémotechnique a ses failles, mais c'est celui que moi, en tout cas, j'utilise.
Et enfin, le dernier : Le poisson.
Populaire, cOnciliant, Idéaliste, Sensible, Soumis, cOmpréhensif, et Négligeant.
Va falloir que ça change, les poissons.
Voilà, vous m'aviez vraiment inspirés avec ces commentaires,  donc je tenais à faire une vidéo dessus.
La vidéo sur la négociation et avoir une augmentation etc, je la ferai quand même la semaine prochaine
c'est juste reporté dans le temps, parce que c'était chouette de rebondir.
Et sur ce côté assez drôle que j'ai pu vérifier par moi-même que les gens se reconnaissent dans les descriptifs de leur signe
même si ce n'est pas ce qu'ils sont vraiment.
N'oubliez pas que demain je fais ma FAQ via Twitter
parce qu'il fallait passer par Twitter pour changer un  petit peu les réseaux sur lesquels je fais les FAQ.
C'est la FAQ pour fêter les 30000, donc le hashtag pour poser votre question qui doit être en rapport avec les vidéos
c'est : #mentalisme30000, le mentalisme du futur.
Vous avez encore jusqu'à ce soir 20h, après je vais faire la vidéo.
Merci d'avoir regardé celle-ci, si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir en mettant un petit et imprévisible, mais astrologique...
pouce en l'air !
Vous pouvez également laisser un commentaire, je lis tous les commentaires.
En ce moment, j'y répond moins. J'y répondrai plus plus tard.
Je suis en train de vous préparer les vidéos de cet été.
Merci à tous ceux et celles qui font des sous-titres ! Il y a vos noms à chaque fois en bas des descriptifs
dès que vous faites des sous-titres. C'est automatisé par Youtube.
Et ça rend les vidéos accessibles aux mal-entendants, donc bravo!
De temps en temps, je pense à vous le dire parce que vraiment, vous le méritez
je sais que vous passez du temps là-dessus.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir, puisque le mental vlog, c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an
depuis le 1er janvier, donc rendez-vous demain 17h.
Ciao